>>Peter: For whatever
reason, kids come to us
with some significant
gaps in their math.
But more important, they come to
us with some poor math habits.
What we're using Khan for,
basically, is it's a way
of reengaging them in the math.
>>I'll leave that up there, use
that as your model if you need it.
Go into Khan System
Elimination 0.5.
If you do that easily,
if you finish that,
move onto the
Elimination 1.0.
>>These are primarily sophomores;
they've taken algebra
before and did not pass.
We started out with some
relatively easy problems,
systems of elimination.
This is 0.5.
There's a model on the board for them
to sort of follow, talk to each other
if they need a little bit of help,
ask me if they need
a little bit of help.
When they're in Khan, basically
a problem is presented
and they can choose to watch a video
or more often what they'll
do is choose to see hints.
The hints are basically the steps.
It's not uncommon for a problem to
be broken down into five or seven
or eight steps with some brief
explanations about what each step is.
>>Student: Yes, so what
I did was take a hint.
So like, what it basically says,
"Beginning by moving the Y term
in the second equation to the
right side of the equation..."
>>David: And you can ask for a hint.
You can watch a video.
You can ask a peer.
So you've got three opportunities
to try and help yourself and then
after that, you raise your hands.
The teacher is working with the
students that he or she needs
to be working with at that time.
And other kids, for the most part,
are engaged in doing
what they're doing.
So it really changes the
dynamic between the teacher
and students in the classroom.
>>Peter: And I can see where they're
proficient and where they're not.
>>The teacher has access to something
called Coach Mode and it allows us
to go in and see a variety of things.
At a glance, I can see it for
the whole class, you know,
how many exercises they've completed,
who's progressed and who hasn't.
And there's a variety of
other ways I can go in
and get a quick assessment
of where students are.
>>If I want to pick a particular
exercise, I can go in here.
And see this student
has some difficulty;
watched the video,
took a number of hints.
>>When I'm working with a student
one on one, I can go even deeper
and see the specific
problems they've tried.
I can see the steps that they took.
I can get some sense of
where they went wrong.
>>Student: I could
definitely do the work.
>>Peter: So here.
So write down the problem.
>>Historically, it was really
hard to get the kids engaged.
They couldn't get the help
right when they wanted it.
There was no immediate feedback
if it was right or wrong.
It was easy for them to sort of get
lost and just sort of drift in class.
Well, now they have to keep moving
because they know we're keeping track
of the problems they're
finishing and they want
to see the progress bar move;
they want to see themselves become
proficient in the exercises.
>>Student: I hope I'm getting two Ys.
>>Peter: Yes, you plug it in the...
>>Student: I know.
>>Peter: Trust me, you got it.
>>Peter: Previously, we had a hard
time getting the kids to do homework.
Well, now with Khan, it's a little bit
easier to get them to do that work.
There's less wiggle room
for them to sort of back
out because they've got hints they
can take or videos they can watch
and you're measuring
the work they're doing.
Student: I kind of don't know this...
>>Peter: And they're doing
many more problems this year
than they did last year.
And there's no substitute
for practice.
>>Student: And the good thing about
it is it tells us when we need
to review it and we could
go back and take hints again
or we can just keep on going.
>>Peter: Their behavior,
their habits were changing.
We started to notice these
kids were staying engaged.
We'd look at screens of our coaching
data and see kids repeatedly trying.
Watch the video here;
he's taking some hints.
They're taking ownership and they're
developing more of an attitude
of "I'm going to figure this out."
>>Move on to adding segments.
I'll pull one of those
up shortly too, okay.
>>But then what we started to
notice too was a real difference
in their test scores.
The average score is up about 30
to 40 percentage points and many,
many more students in
the advanced range.
>>Multiplied by negative two.
>> What is it about Khan that works?
Part of it is the fact
that it's simply a computer
and there's something engaging
about anything on computers.
I think that it's an important
part that it's one on one,
the fact that they can get help right
now on this problem at this step.
So that immediacy, that
individuality is a big part of it.
But I think something about the
design of Khan in particular,
you know, it's not multiple choice
so you can't guess your way through.
The problems are randomly
generated so you can't copy
from another student; you
would have to do the work.
>>Student: I was doing
the top one here.
>>Peter: Okay.
>>Student: But then I did
the bottom one right there.
>>David: It shows us that
every single student,
when given the chance,
wants to learn.
They want to be successful.
We're seeing students just turn
on, you know, left and right.
>>Peter: We see more focus.
We see more attentiveness.
We see more engagement.
We see the kids this year less
apt to give up in the first couple
of seconds and the basic
skills are also better
because they've been
engaged, they've done the work
and that's the real magic.